you changed both of our lives when you
got on the plane so
i'm really glad you took that chance
yo matter of fact man burnham jones man
you do know that poppy runs one of the
best restaurants in that lake right i
don't mean he know how to make a
westerly cheese thing feel me
and i'm will by the way
lisa
not gonna lie i'm loving the kicks with
the suit cuts quite a figure from a
distance oh yeah
how about a close
it's pretty nice up close too yeah
now you look pretty good too
mona lisa
yeah order up silly
no
pardon me yo looking out yo
brother
oh
oh
this going crazy so uh heard there was
this beach party tonight
pulling up
wait you're not are you
you're carlton's cousin
carlton's my ex
i mean i wasn't asking you to be my girl
or nothing
just wondering if you were going to the
party i'm thinking about it
okay
you think i'm free
good luck at the game tomorrow well
holy [ __ ] the thirst ha don't be mad
cause they feeling your boy i'm not
nobody bad it's only because you're on
the basketball team
i wish you were following me too
yeah but
we're just friends remember
yeah
i remember
so friend hmm you come to the basketball
game
you know we playing malibu prep so i'ma
drop 30 on them come see me my ballet
jersey it's my first game tempting but
i've got a swim meet so maybe i'll swing
by after maybe i'll swing by after boy
stop playing
oh my god i'm so sorry
are you ready i'm so are you really
sorry
come on lisa
it's getting worse
she was my mom's favorite artist was as
in past tense
my mom died three years ago
like this
damn
i'm sorry uh i didn't know that
i usually only talk about her to people
that knew her you know that understand
how amazing she was
but if we're gonna be friends
it's part of who i am
that's real
i appreciate you sharing that with me
and um
i'm glad we're friends
me too
so
you still coming to my uncle's
fundraiser tomorrow or what cause i'm
really trying to see what you do in
those skates all right please i glide
okay okay you know that roller skating
scene atl
that's me oh that's you it's me okay
okay we're gonna see new new wilks
don't make me have to snatch that chain
hey
you're uh
lisa's dad
she didn't tell me you were a
cop
los angeles chief of police
oh
you all right son yes
yes just uh
when i met you at my uh knocks party
i didn't realize you were a cop
it
just kind of throws me
that don't worry kid
you're not in trouble
i don't understand why it matters if my
dad's a cop he's the chief of police and
if it didn't matter why don't you tell
me
i wasn't hiding anything
it's not like you told me what your dad
did for a living oh sorry i can't answer
that question because i haven't seen the
sorry ass [ __ ] since he walked out
i'm sorry i didn't i didn't know that's
fine
but that's not worth talking about
well it's fine all right
have fun
wait will
i thought it'd be fitting for me to read
the words that i wrote
for my mom
and joining me in this reading is my
good friend
will smith
[Applause]
you forever changed the world mom
your spirit lives on
echoing the sweetest sounds boundless
and radiant
flowing through every ocean
every sunrise
every sunset you forever change the
world your warmth your wisdom like the
sun and the moon your energy is still
with us
present and abundant
just like the stars above us shining
bright
until the end of time
my dreams know you well
you visit them often so every morning
i find the strength to smile knowing you
forever changed the world
i love you mom
[Applause]
so is there a reason that you've been so
distant lately
i don't want to be another person in
your life that you have to navigate
around
you know
lisa
i think you are
the most amazing girl
i've ever known
i mean that
but
i don't want to bring any more drama in
your life so if that means i got to back
off give you enough space you know what
i mean
i'll do that
even if it hurts
is that what you want
i don't know
no
but
me neither
[Music]
is
[Music]
never
talk about why you came out here
dad i'm not gonna be your spy
not asking you to be
you got a good heart will
strong conscious and moral code and the
closer you get to lisa
the more you may feel the pressure to
open up to her
you know
be transparent
you don't want to put yourself in a
position where
you have to lie to somebody you care
about
sometimes
it's better to create a little distance
you feel me
what i'm asking
is for you to take a step back from
willing the bank's family go into their
house social activities any interactions
until the election is over
i know it's not fair
that's just how it has to be
for now
why did you really come here from philly
well first my name is will
and uh
i came here from philly
for a better education
you know
just like i said it's simple
yeah yeah
because my aunt and uncle they presented
an opportunity and i was just like
i just want to take the jazz
leaving home moving across the country
starting over it takes a lot of courage
well
it's not that hard
and you changed both of our lives when
you got on the plane so
i'm really glad you took that chance
um
damn those charges do work fast you want
to go back down to the party
or we could stay here
yeah
okay
[Music]
mmm
um
you okay with this
because
if this is moving too fast
i'm good
i trust you
[Music]
[Music]
don't even think about answering that
we're not done i'm telling you you're
wrong about him i wish i was but i know
for a fact he's trouble you have to stop
seeing you keep saying that but how
could you know anything about him
judge robertson sent me this
after he decided to back me in my
campaign
will was arrested after a fight in
philadelphia there was a gun involved
phillip banks reached out to robertson
for a favor to make it all go away which
he did
unfortunately
i can't believe you'd stooped this low
to win the election stoop a man who
would circumvent the law like that
doesn't deserve to be d.a lisa you're
assuming that it really happened and
it's not just some lies robertson told
you
well go ask will yourself if that's what
it's gonna take but once you know the
truth that better be the last time you
speak with him
hey
what's up
tell me this isn't you will
[Music]
how did you find that does it matter
is it you this isn't what it looks like
[Music]
are you gonna speak
ugh lisa hold on hold on don't leave
don't leave then tell me something that
doesn't make it seem so bad that you
lied to me about who you really are and
why you're here
lisa i took up for you
every time my dad told me to stay away
from you and like an idiot i defended
you when he told me that you were
trouble
oh i can't believe he was right
lisa
can we talk
hold on
please
lisa listen
i'm sorry i'm sorry
and i have no excuse
this is so [ __ ] up will
why would you lie because i feel like i
need to respect uncle phil
when he told me not to tell her i hid
nothing from you
i caught hell for you and damn it well
we had sex and i
i feel like i don't know the first thing
about you lisa please don't say that
like i'll tell you everything
i will tell you everything
okay
[Music]
did you shoot someone
no
i shot a gun
into the air
to break up a fight
so your uncle did break the law
yeah
to help me
said i wouldn't even be here if it
wasn't for him
but thank you for finally being honest
but my dad knows well
and he's gonna use it against your uncle
at the debate tense robinson totally
look lisa please you cannot let that
there's nothing that i can do you did
what you did and he did what he did you
can't blame anyone else for what happens
now
lisa
listen i gotta see my piece and then i
won't bother you anymore
why can't you just accept the fact that
this is over because i love you
i love you
that's why
i can't let you walk away without
knowing that
you're just saying that to try and get
me back i promise he said you have my
heart
i have never felt this way before about
anyone in my life
and if you can't forgive me
and i just gotta look at that
but i had to let you know
how much you mean to me
we can't do this now we're here but
you should know that i
won't talk to her
[Music]
no need to come down
[Music]